yeah today's data telling us what we
already knew which was that living costs
Rises are hard for everyone but under
scoring just how bad they are the
households on Lower incomes now to bring
this to life let's look at a case study
meet Steve and Tanya a couple in their
40s with three teenage children Tanya
Works in a catering role at the local
school and Steve is a full-time carer
looking after two elderly parents
Stephen Tanya's monthly budget this is
what it looked like a year ago to
understand it start at the left with the
blue bars as we go up there is Tanya's
salary coming in every month augmented
by government support Universal Credit
and child support payments that takes
them to about three thousand pounds a
month of income from which they have to
pay tax rent
bills including energy bills of course
and cost of Essentials like food and
fuel leaving them last year with about
400 pounds a month of spending money
they're getting by
wind forward same family to this month
and it's a much less Rosy picture
salaries have gone up a little
but look at what's happened to rent look
at what's happened to their energy costs
and look at what's happened to their
food bills as a result scraping past at
best
let's take those in turn because there's
a lot of families in the same situation
what today's data from the ons tells us
is that something like 40 percent of
families on those modest income levels
are finding it hard to keep up with
their mortgage and rent payments and
fully one in ten households is already
falling behind on their energy bills if
they're renting that's before winter and
before prices of energy rise again in
April so we turn to food a tough picture
particularly for household shopping on a
tight budget because it's the lowest
cost foods that have risen in price the
most just look at what's happened to
Pasta prices they've risen for all of us
by a third
but the cheapest passer on the
supermarket shelves has gone up 60
similarly sharply Rising costs of tea
and other Staples so a poorer household
like time you're in to use on a lower
income is really facing the pinch but it
gets worse if the current trends
continue for a further year even if the
government increases their benefits
payments in line with inflation
Tanya and Steve with Rising rent costs
increased energy prices and other costs
are going to be digging themselves into
a whole come October next year and
that's the challenge that the new prime
minister faces he's told us that he
wants to be compassionate
but if compassion costs this household a
thousand pounds a year of extra support
does the government have the capital
does it have the borrowing power to
support these households in a time of
crisis